[Musique]
informer les élèves du collège paul
saint fort du robert sur le harcèlement
en milieu scolaire et sur les dangers
des réseaux sociaux
si l'objectif de ce procès fictif il met
en scène une jeune fille dans les
camarades de classe ont diffusé des
photos montages insultants sur les
réseaux sociaux
une opération de sensibilisation
organisée par l'association des deux
victimes va vers les victimes ou leurs
informée de l'endroit
c'est une façon ludique pédagogique des
formes et les enfants sur leurs droits
également les agresseurs leur expliquer
ce que dit la loi
un message efficace et semble-t-il à
porter ses fruits auprès d'i télé ça ne
devrait pas se passer
[Musique]
passez un consulat ont seulement pu tuer
et que si on est victime de sabeton
n'aurait pas aimé parce qu'il ne faut
pas tout ça il ne faut pas avoir peur de
le dire comme ça mais les fautifs ils
sont l'association des victimes qui
porte cette action spa que cette
simulation de procès pourra se monter
dans d'autres établissements scolaires